let's uh let's let's talk about this
movie let me see if i can find this one
here we go
this is from the daily mail
holy wokery batgirl tom leonard
investigates why warner bros 90 million
new superhero movie has been deemed so
awful it will never be released so i saw
this and i really wanted to talk about
it because a massive get woke go broke
apparently they put 90 million dollars
into a batgirl film that was super woke
and they canceled it because when they
showed it to people the people said this
is a terrible movie and you shouldn't
have made it and so they scrapped it
it's a lot of money to scrap i kind of
want to see it now i yeah apparently
that's what's happening people are
saying like give us the film and we'll
finish it let us see but i bet it's
really bad yeah i bet it like
i think we can't hate watch stuff or
even like curiosity watch stuff like
that they'll be like oh so you did buy a
ticket so we should make this like if
they canceled it just let it go like
that's probably good
the audience feedback was so awful that
an almost unprecedented move warner
brothers has decided the reputational
damage of releasing such a dud would be
even worse than wasting the tens of
millions of dollars that already spent
on it it just didn't work said an
insider the decision is also a blow for
glasgow which has stood in uh for
glasgow which had stood in for gotham
city in the movie okay that's weird look
at this the lead i don't know but this
costume looks like it's
like
crappy cosplay well they already failed
because we all know that female
superheroes are supposed to wear um mini
skirts and stuff but this is uh this is
but then that's like over sexualizing
her so like can't do that either yeah
they trapped themselves into a corner
where they couldn't market this film
it's not clear who this audience is for
i think this may be the end of what
audience was in movies i think this
shows 90 million dollar end
they spent a ton of money realized they
made garbage that nobody wanted
i mean how long did it take for people
to finally realize when they're like you
know
maybe your average dude doesn't want to
see a super ripped woman punching people
in the face
maybe and your average woman doesn't
want to see that either exactly
yeah you know i think it was it might
have been
bill burr or i can't remember which
comedian it was they said funny they
said that uh the wnba should we're all
the feminists all the feminists should
be out there watching the wnba but
there's nobody there where the woman at
nobody watches it because nobody cares i
want to watch it
exactly i don't want to watch men's
battle what what is this obsession with
like creating men's things for women
that women don't want and men don't want
this is such a weird thing too and
especially in in films and you know
narrative because what they do is they
say let's take this this character that
is a male character and let's just turn
it into a female character and do
exactly the same things with it that we
would do with a male character and then
it's like you know feminist and forward
thinking and progressive and all of that
but if you're going to build a female
character you have to build a female
character that is female at the core you
can't just like
gloss over
you know you can't just like basically
trans a male character in a narrative i
think i know how to do it
how to trans male character how to make
batgirl work for women
here's what you do
it's batgirl right she's a crime
fighting superhero
and then she starts dating batman and he
like is totally into bdsm and is like
choking her and stuff
you know like because fifty shades of
fresh shades are great i mean women love
that okay but the perfect one was the
the michael keaton batman with
who was it was it michelle pfeiffer was
catwoman catwoman that was great it was
romantic it was it was actiony she was
cool
everyone wanted to be catwoman that
halloween but it's catwoman it's not cat
and there's no cat man because it's like
that's a female character from we
shouldn't make yeah but every grade
school kid knows that you know cats are
girls and dogs are boys everyone thinks
it's just the way it is but it is it's
weird everyone thinks cats are girls
okay i'm like i don't understand the
lion female it's like we have we have uh
bocus and people are like what's what's
her name and i'm like it's a dude i mean
he's a eunuch right but he's a dude
and he eunuchs or something
yeah
no but my point was like if you were
going to make a
women want different things right i made
this point a couple days ago i made it
several times the past week when i was
on this plane
and we got hit by wind and we fell like
50 feet you just drop
every single one on the plane screams
not a single male did
because like men and women are different
yeah i would i would scream probably
what is the screaming from mostly i
would gasp i don't know but like why did
i scream
the uh the the hypothesis from
evolutionary psychology is that if a
bear if a threat uh if a woman perceives
a threat and she doesn't scream she's
more likely to die oh so screaming
alerts the males of danger crying kids
the screamers had the babies the little
girls in my neighborhood when i was a
kid would have screaming contests
oh wow yeah to make sure and it would be
dusk and i would be like at home because
i had to be home by dusk and i would
hear like these screaming and the
neighbors would get so mad everyone
would be like you kids stop screaming we
think something's wrong with you
i think something's wrong oh you think
you need help and they were like it's
just a screaming contest mr laurier
we would have pee in contests we didn't
do that
i can tell you
up on top of the clubhouse that's weird
yeah i'd win a lot of those
congratulations to the cemetery thanks
into the cemetery we got a cemetery
pissing onto graves never made it to a
grave oh okay ain't too far out
that's horrifying anyway my point was i
i saw this story i want to talk about it
because i'm thinking like it's been it's
been over a decade
since the rise of wokeness
and now we see like critical race theory
critical gender theory but this is huge
because if they're willing to tank 90
million dollars without and they don't
want anyone to see this
you know maybe they're starting to
realize it
this stuff doesn't work the old stories
are not bad stories the old narratives
are there for a reason they've lasted
thousands of years for reasons it's
because we relate to them we understand
them it's because they're part of the
the narrative that we use to tell
ourselves the story of humanity and the
story of our lives did you guys catch
tomb raider or ever follow that game or
movie yeah it was what's her name played
yeah
is there like any desire or interest in
like a woman with a sword that's a
badass fighter
hold on hold on but you don't get it i
recently watched tomb raider because it
was recommended on amazon and it's
clearly just a movie for for dudes dude
like angelino jolie's boobs are like
mushed forward and pointy like the tomb
raider character because they only had
polygons or whatever they're very few
polygons and there's actually like
a scene of her just naked in the shower
for no reason yeah it's like the movie
was clearly not for girls to be like
yeah like i'm going to be strong like
her and i was like dudes watching a big
breasted woman there are like there are
fun movies that are like actiony
rom-commy type movies like i was
thinking about this the other day
remember shawn to the dead shawn of the
dead was great romantic comedy with
zombies
i love that movie see boom there it is
meg moore i've been told i have bad
taste in movies i love that movie always
fantastic it's great uh
but um what was i saying before i got
sidetracked by that movie oh you
remember the uh remember heather used to
be all those old movies with uh michael
douglas and kathleen turner
do you guys know okay are you talking
about okay what's what's an example
what's one of them ant-man
they did a movie called romancing the
stone which was kind of like it was kind
of like indiana jones but they were
teamed up at the beginning and they
hated each other and then they fall in
love and everybody gets soaking wet in
the waterfall and there's diamonds and
things and then they go off on some
paradise because they're rich now you
know what women fantasize about this is
this is like what these movies were and
they did very well
now they're like let's just have a woman
be like a super ripped muscular boxer
yeah she hates men yeah and has
absolutely and you can't tell at all
what her priorities are or what she
wants in life like what do these
characters want and then
the men are one-dimensional and they're
like you can't be a boxer you're a woman
according to romance in the stone they
want overcoming miscommunication so like
they didn't like each other then they
realized oh we actually do like each
other right they want adventure
um and to be rich
and then right to retire and comfort and
to look good doesn't mean you look fine
while you're doing it yeah there was a
there was like kathleen turner there was
a meme in the 80s that might not be true
but someone posted on the internet and
went viral they said the male power
fantasy is to save
everyone the children the women other
men to put the fire out to be a
superhero
that's why guys love these movies war
movies it's to like save everyone and
the female power fantasy is to be able
to do whatever you want without
consequences so in like a lot of
romantic comedies it's about the
bumbling you know woman who just gets
what she wants in the end you know
through his adventure or something i'd
argue the woman in uh i don't remember
her name but gone girl like that female
character is crazy to me i would watch
her all day long because she gets to do
whatever she wants because she's
operating on a really intense
psychological level i think women
i i have never really been interested in
watching girls fight like physical
combat with women if you're if that's
what you want to watch fine but i don't
think it has the same appeal for a
female character as seeing female
characters
control a situation psychologically or
through emotion i think that's much more
of a feminine trait than seeing them
punch someone and that's why when you
see really real well-written characters
they are in some ways reflective of true
gender norms
i think that's really interesting you're
making me i keep thinking about game of
thrones i don't you probably guys
probably have seen it if not but there's
this character called uh brienne of
tarth there was this woman who that was
like a warrior and she was huge she's
like five or something and she's pretty
big for a woman but they put her in this
armor and she could barely move in the
armor it was like
grating and embarrassing to watch and it
society didn't want to talk about how
how horribly awkward it was to put this
woman in this massive heavy armor she
could barely move but they were just
like trying to shove it down my throat
like this is what a woman wore you're
like dude at least like put her in
something she can
she can
carry
like so it doesn't look embarrassing
like oh it's just
disgusting to watch it was really really
piss-poor
that they did that i'm sorry you had to
watch that yeah it was it was like and i
you know i didn't even realize how bad
it was until halfway through this
i just can't lie to myself anymore the
casting of brie larson is is captain
marvel for those that are familiar just
made literally no sense to me because
she's like a short frail woman who's
supposed to be this like great warrior
this massively super powerful being and
i'm just like pick your narrative man
like what are you going for
you're going for a short very thin frail
woman they might as well have cast uh
kristen chenoweth instead i don't know
man well i think all this stuff is going
to start backfiring on them well cause
no one will look it look at look at the
look at
what was that top top gun
like that did great right it was fairly
generic they didn't even mention the
name of the enemy country but i think
this is the same thing in the first half
but anyway and it was good it was just
like a regular movie i thought what you
said was very insightful that women uh
their power fantasy is manipulating
people as opposed to the man is fighting
people because like i've been listening
to a lot of psychologists i think jordan
peterson and other people have been
talking about women like high school
girls will their power thing is they
will manipulate others and make other
girls feel bad about themselves oh yeah
whereas the guys will bully they'll like
push it's much more efficient i mean you
hear people say like with men and women
like women are grudge holders right and
like the idea it's kind of a stereotype
but like guys if the if the argument
gets really heated eventually they'll
just throw punches and then it's kind of
over right they have a way to physically
de-escalate a situation where if with
women we don't i mean some girls do i
guess but like for the most part they
aren't as prone to physical violence
they are much more prone to like social
and emotional manipulation because they
are in some ways more in tune to that
naturally and so like i just have never
really understood these
like why the push to have women be
physical fighters when they actually are
crazy in another realm like they can be
maybe that's why
ocean's eight make a bunch of money the
all-female reboot of ocean's eleven like
actually did really well i don't know
yeah i think it actually made a lot of
money well john
john mullaney had this joke about before
it came out like you could never have an
all-female cast of whatever ocean's
movie because
women you know there would be seven of
them and then two would split off to
talk you know talk about the rest of
them
it doesn't work it's not reflective i
mean with uh thor love and thunder
we talked like
natalie portman got a lot of heat for
like uh her arms actually it's right by
the cgi whatever but what is that
i think to a certain extent yeah i mean
she's petite like even in i from i'm not
an expert please no one judged me on
this but like from the comic books it's
actually like a six foot tall kind of
like
much more athletic looking i imagine
like a volleyball player body type uh
and they chose that i mean maybe natalie
portman is perfect for a lot of other
reasons i can't they cast her in the
role right but they were like it's
better to have this very petite woman
and then it kind of defies expectations
because she's actually a great warrior
or something like i don't understand why
this is appealing at all i don't i don't
think it's that easy there's another
there's another like i think woman's
power fantasy too that i think uh
is very taboo to talk about these days
but that we can hear in you know old pop
music for example like if you look at
amy winehouse on holy war right so the
fantasy in that song is that she's gonna
back her man no matter what
if you look at like um a song that i
recently remembered and started
listening to i was like oh that's great
uh midnight train to georgia right
gladys knight
she's singing about how this man she's
in love with is leaving la because his
dreams didn't turn out right and he's
going back to georgia and she's like i'm
totally going with him you know i would
never know songwriting is so much better
you know
but amy winehouse and you know gladys
knight and there's others you know like
you hear it i think in some aretha songs
as well
um but this idea that the
the fantasy isn't about
uh your own aggrandizement or your own
you know success or power manipulation
but you know your greatness lies in
boosting your man you know and like
the whole power behind the throne thing
yeah i mean i think i say manipulation
but like really women if you think of
like the stereotype of like
hunter-gatherer right like the men go
out and they have to like be physical
they have to hunt and capture things but
women stay home and basically hang out
with the other women and the kids and
they have to keep an eye on what's going
on like there is a different skill set
that's needed to do that i don't i mean
maybe they would fight in the village
but for the most part you really have to
learn how to navigate socially that's
why
just take a look at the noble
domesticated follow
oh yes the chicken the chicken and the
rooster
and now the rooster will run into danger
sacrificing himself to protect the hens
when you watch the chickens eating all
the ladies are like pecking the ground
and the roosters standing upright just
looking around he's like nobody coming
near my ladies
and then they're sweet if a fox will
come it doesn't seem that way well at
first at first but it is it is i mean
and then he takes what he wants sure you
know what i'm saying and the chickens
just you know they're like right here
you can hear them yeah do you think they
think like here he comes when he comes
walking in the room sometimes they run
and it's like really really crazy to
watch like the chickens are like just
frantic and the bruiser's chasing him
but no like if a fox shows up the
rooster will run straight at it knowing
it will die
giving the hens time to flee have you
seen this has this has this happened on
chicken city we had a hawk attack no way
and the rooster ran towards the gate and
then stood in front of it making noises
as the hens all ran in and then he went
in last wow yeah it was crazy to watch
he was like not going to go in until all
the girls were inside that's cool but
like the hens are really dumb so i think
what he was doing was he went to the
door as a small little door
to show them where it was they so
they'll follow him and then he waits
outside for them to get safe and then
the hawk i think the hawk actually got
hit one of our chickens and then
wasn't able to get off with it and then
the you know the rooster
roberto but roberto's been retired he
was just he was banging his daughters
too much you know yeah you can't stop he
can't let that go well in chicken
society it's called line breeding it's
kind of okay but when he has too many
kids then it's like okay buddy like
you're you're off yeah but no thanks we
uh you were right about ocean's eight
the uh the sequel all women's sequel it
budgeted 70 million to make and they
made 300 million worldwide because it
was about a bunch of women who were
manipulative and catty and stole a bunch
of money from dudes
it made slightly less than ocean's 13
but it also costs slightly less to make
so see there you go seem like they're
just doing so so you want to do a movie
about women make them sly and
manipulative
people are going to be all down for it
oh and tell women stories as opposed to
like just grafting women on top of men's
stories yeah i like the idea of
supporting the man only because the man
then supports the children yeah i mean
this is an old story right this is like
an old classic narrative like the
there's the bible story who is it is it
i'm gonna get the name wrong is it
esther it's one of them right and she
ends up married to
the king or whatever and he's not jewish
and she's not his biggest fan but like
he she ends up bringing him around and
then he does right by the
by the israelites and it all works out
we should we should make a movie where
it's like the main characters are the
women who are married to the superheroes
and then like all the superhero stuff is
just ancillary background stuff like mob
wives is that what it is i don't know
but it seems like that would be what
that would be and i was gonna say but
it's just like the women doing things
that support the infrastructure behind
the superhero and so it's more of like
an interpersonal drama yeah the show
should be called superheroes but it's
about the women no this is a great idea
and it shouldn't be called that but i
like this
but i like this idea this would be a
really fun film this would be a really
fun film to write and to watch and to
costume i mean this would be great
costumes if it was like actually writ
written as like a story women were
interested in hearing as opposed to just
like making the women big burly
superheroes punching guys right no i
mean this is not a movie that hollywood
would produce right now because we
aren't supposed to have women who are
like
secondary or playing wives and mother
figures right like that's not supposed
to be but it would be great but that's
the story that most women are starting
at like
a day party you know and like all the
moms are coming over and there's like a
pool party and all the kids have like
weird things they can do because their
dads are superheroes and they're all
just today be fantastic but then you
gotta have a villain like slams down
from the sky and attacks the party
that's if you want to get everyone to
like it no the the villain would be
the wife i feel like it's always
happening in the background dylan would
be like yeah that would be the wife of
the super villain and she would come in
and you would think she's the villain
and then it would turn out that she's
actually really nice and no no she
invites everyone to like the
i don't know it turns out
it turns out the villain is the super
villain's wife and the superhero's wife
and the villains were fighting because
they were at a department store and
there was one cute dress on sale and the
villain's wife bought it first okay
that's nice and now they just
you know
like you guys are out of the writer's
room you're just throwing
no but it would be like this
but if you want to go really classic it
would obviously there would be some sort
of a fair situation
an affair yeah so like the villain the
super villain's wife is actually like
having an affair with like the oh that's
actually the chad super hero yeah and
also
the chad superhero's wife is actually
like she's the leader you know because
there's always a leader there's always
there's always a head of the girl back
so she's in charge and then it turns out
and blah blah blah yeah actually it's
much more interpersonal like i get what
you're saying like it might be nice to
have someone explode but yeah and like
the the the superhero the top
superhero's wife's best friend would
start to know about the affair yeah she
doesn't know if she should tell there's
ethical conflict we're not complicated
guys
then you get the superhero in the white
house it's a really good film but it
would like the lighting should be really
bright like that should be really
like um nature colors like almost a
little overexposed and it's like a weird
suburb of some kind yes yes
yeah so i hope someone's writing all
this down because this is this is gold
oh we don't have to right right
nobody the thing is too like
the the social consequences of the
superhero dating a super villain like
having an affair with super villain's
wife yeah and then his wife's friend
finds out he's got to talk to her about
it they get secluded in a room or just
gotta confront her what happens when the
pop when the public hears that
you know he's intimate with
you know the family he's villains one
time it happened one time nobody's gone
didn't happen one time and then you have
like these great scenes like at a like
at a run-down roadside motel
you know and you have like the loud
sound of like real potatoes and
uh the weird guy who's like smoking
cigars and it's sort of like the light
is weird and then you cut to a scene of
like their kids playing together but you
got about it you got to do something you
got to do it suicide no you got it no
suicide but like the villain's wife stop
you don't get me okay yeah i'll just
give you you gotta do a scene we're like
the wife of the chad superhero like goes
to confront him and she finds him at
this old motel and it's like
thunderstorming
and then she's like catches him in the
room and then she screams and she storms
out and then he runs out after and
they're both in the rain and he's like
don't do this and she's like you did to
me and they're arguing in this rain
pouring down and then he picks her up
and they kiss in the rain right and then
we have a and then we have a you know
stand by my man moment like
and the only way that she can stand by
the man is they got to get rid of the
villain wife and now they're like super
villains but that's ultimately feeding
the conflict between the super villain
and the hero yeah and then they leave
town and then you have a sequel because
now the villain and the villain's wife
had to start over somewhere else no no
no no turns out they're villains they're
into it they're swingers
yeah but they still have to leave they
can't go to the pool parties anymore oh
yeah you can't and like then you have
the kids being like why can't we play
with evil junior i don't understand
she only wears versace yes yes yes she's
a rap dress girl
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there